إذا استفاد معظم الأمريكيين الذين يبلغون من العمر 50 عامًا فأكثر
من جرعة معززة ثانية ،
أعتقد أن معظم الأمريكيين الذين يبلغون من العمر 50 عامًا أو أكبر
يجب أن يحصلوا على أول جرعة معززة في
الواقع أعتقد أن كل شخص
مؤهل يجب أن يفعل ذلك ، ومع ذلك فإن
نصف الأمريكيين فقط المؤهلين للحصول على
هذا الطعام أولاً  لقد حصلت على التعزيز
لذا فإن أول شيء والثاني
هو أننا نعلم أن التطعيم
بالإضافة إلى ذلك التعزيز الأول لا يزال
يحميك جيدًا بما في ذلك ضد
الأمراض الشديدة وبالتالي قد يرغب بعض الأشخاص في
الحصول على مستوى إضافي من الحماية
إذا كان عمرك يزيد عن 65 عامًا  إذا كنت تعاني من حالات
طبية مزمنة وكان عمرك يزيد عن 50 عامًا ،
فقد ترغب في الحصول على تلك الجرعة الرابعة
ولكنها ليست شيئًا يحتاج الجميع
إلى الحصول عليه الآن لأن هذا يعني بالنسبة للعديد من
الأشخاص الحصول على أربع
جرعات من الكوفيد في غضون عام تقريبًا  هل
هناك أي جانب سلبي للحصول على الكثير من
المعززات أو الحصول عليها بشكل جيد في كثير من الأحيان ،
فهناك جانب سلبي عملي وهو
أن الفائدة الإضافية للجرعة الرابعة
على  يبدو أن الجرعة الثالثة
قصيرة العمر وقد يقرر الكثير من الناس
الانتظار حتى يكون هناك زيادة حقيقية
لأن مستويات الحالة
في الولايات المتحدة في الغلاف 19
منخفضة جدًا في الواقع ، وقد يقرر بعض الأشخاص
الانتظار حتى يكون هناك عدد أكبر من الحالات
قبل أن يحصلوا على الجرعة الرابعة ولكن
من ناحية أخرى ، إذا كنت تعاني من
نقص المناعة إذا كنت تعاني من حالات
طبية مزمنة ، فقد تقرر
أنه من أجل صحتك ، قد ترغب في
اتخاذ هذا القرار الفردي
بتخفيض الجرعة الرابعة ، فقد يرغب بعض الأشخاص
في تعظيم  مساحة الحماية
خارج الوقت بين اللقطات ، هل يمكنهم
تأجيل معززهم إلى أن
يحصلوا على ما في أقرب وقت ممكن ،
حيث يتساءل الكثير من الناس ،
نعم ، أعتقد أن الأمر يعتمد حقًا على
ظروفك الفردية ، على سبيل المثال
إذا كنت فقط  أوميكرون متعاقد ،
سأنتظر إذا تم تطعيمك معززًا
وأن لديك أوميكرون ، فأنت محمي جيدًا في
الوقت الحالي ، لن أحصل على هذه
الجرعة الإضافية ولكن على  من ناحية أخرى ، إذا
كنت أكثر عرضة لدرجة
أنه من الممكن أن ينتهي بك الأمر في
المستشفى إذا أصبت بأي
عدوى في الجهاز التنفسي ، فهذه فكرة جيدة للحصول
على الجرعة المنشطة الرابعة